من غرفه الاجتماعات ننطلق لنقول قريبا
ربما تلغى نصف الاجتماعات التي لا طائل
عملي منها ليس الموظفون من يملون من
الاجتماعات فحسب اليوم المدراء ايضا
اصبحوا غير مقتنعين بكل هذه الاجتماعات
غير المشتهيه وبحسب دراسه استقصائيه لموقع
زوم فان المدراء يقولون ان اكثر من نصف
الاجتماعات لم تعد مجديه بما فيه الكفايه
لاستمرار بعقدها ورغم تحول الاجتماعات الى
الافتراضيه عبر القنوات الالكترونيه
المختلفه الا انها ما زالت تسبب الكثير من
الخسائر في الوقت والمال والجهدات
والتفاصيل مع كيلاميس
بحسب تفاصيل دراسه الاستقصائيه اجرائها
موقع على اكثر من عشره الاف موظفه مدير
فان المدراء التنفيذيين يقضون اكثر من 25
ساعه من الاسبوع في الاجتماعات الدراسه
تقول ان السبب الرئيسي لهذه الاجتماعات
غير المنتجه الاعتقاد الخاطئ انها ستكون
استخداما جيدا للوقت في العمل
الموظفون المشاركون بالاستطلاع يقولون ان
حضورهم يكون في العدد خشيه ان يفوتهم شيء
هام قد يذكر فيما يقول البعض منهم انه ليس
لديهم خيار اخر الا الحضور وبحسب الدراسات
الاخيره فان الاجتماعات غير المجديه تهدر
ما يزيد عن 100 بليون دولار سنويا في
المؤسسات الكبرى ومنذ عشرين عشرين زادت
الاجتماعات الافتراضيه لتصل الى اكثر من
42% فيما يؤكد المدراء التنفيذيون انه
يمكن التخلص مما يزيد عن 46% من
الاجتماعات
[موسيقى]
يسعد صباحك هلا بهالطله اهلا بك
صباحك يا رب قاعد
يعني بحسب الدراسه الاستقصائيه
في الاجتماعات وعلى نصف هذه الاجتماعات ان
تختفي او تلغى ما رايك بذلك
عمليه موضوع جميل جدا
انت متخيله انه نصف تقريبا سته واربعين في
الميه يعني فخلينا نقول يعني ايش الاشياء
خلينا نعامل الاجتماع كانه لقاءات الصباح
العربيه لو حصل الموضوع بهذا الطريقه
ستكون الاجتماعات اكثر انتاجيه في الحياه
كيف الفكره انه لازم يكون عندي مدير
الاجتماع
متحدثين موضوع نناقشه ضابط للوقت ومتابع
للمخرجات في هذه الحاله انا متحدث
المتحدثين معي نادين وسهام الضابط حتكون
الاستاذه اشواق الكنترول المخرجات حتكون
مع ضفاف لما تنزلها في اليوتيوب والاعداد
للموضوع مديره مكتب الاستاذه ضيفي فلو
تعامل الموضوع بهذه الطريقه في موضوع
هنتناقش فيه هو الموضوع الفلاني لازم
تقولي
كم مده الاجتماع من الساعه لانه في
اجتماعات الساعه ثمانيه طب متى ينتهي الله
اعلم لما يكون المدير فالفكره انه لو سار
الاجتماع بوقت محدد من الى وسار المتحدثين
بوقت محدد كل واحد ايش الموضوع اللي
حيتكلم فيه والوقت اللي حيتكلم فيه وفي
متابعه للمخرجات الموضوع هيختلف 180 درجه
تماما حتخرج مخرجات رائعه
انا بعرف انه انت عندك كتير من النقاط
المهمه اللي بدك تحكيها بس احنا كمان
عندنا اسئله حابين هيك نتشاركها معك
الموظف
الموظف ترد طبعه يعني بحب التذمر والشكوى
بشكل عام يعني وبين بعض بقعدوا يشكوا هيك
بس ما ان نذهب الى الاجتماع اول المتذمرين
هم اول الساكتين لماذا هل هذا ما جعل
الاجتماعات بلا فائده وجدوى
اللقاء الماضي يعني كنا بنتكلم عن متى
يتحدث احيانا الصامت لاني انا ماني عارف
الموضوع عن ايش فاني ماني مستعد ما عندي
معلومات كافي اجي اتكلم عنها فانت جايبني
على موضوع
كيف تبغاني اتكلم كيف تبغاني اقول اطلع
شكلي بايخ لما اقول معلومه وتطلع غير
صحيحه ولا بس ادخل مجرد المشاركه والحديث
النقطه الثانيه مدينه تكلمت في نقطه جدا
هامه مو لازم تكون مدير عشان تقود في كتاب
اسمه القائد الذي ليس له منصب في بعض
الشركات
ارجوك لا لا انا بقول على فكره يعني على
المثال عموما في كتاب اسمه القائد الذي
ليس
له مصعفون المدير عشان اقدر اخود ولا يكون
لي اثر فالفكره فين احد الشركات تستعين
بجهه اخرى بخبراء يحضروا اجتماعات يفتحوا
فيها موضوع ويشوفوا كيف اليه الحوار من
المتحدثين لانه احيانا يكون شخص ياخذ زمام
المبادر لما يشوف الاجتماع رايح الى الى
لا كيف الشخص يقول
لموضوعنا اليوم حيكون الموضوع الفل استاذ
فلان يعني لانه احيانا وسط الاجتماع تلاقي
ناس كتير يتكلموا هذا يتكلم في جهه ايش
رايكم بس نسمع واحد واحد عشان يعني نخرج
بملخص افضل نطلع بنتيجه افضل انت لو اخذتي
دور القياده في هذا النقطه واخذت هذا هذا
الحوار هذول المراقبين بيقولوا نادين اللي
تنفع تكون قائده في هذا المنصب هذيك مثال
على بعض الاجتماعات اللي تخرج بلا فائده
احد اكبر الشركات على مستوى المملكه
فروعها هي الاكثر انتشارا على مستوى
المملكه عندهم في احد الاجتماعات فكره
رائعه جابها المديره تنفيذي من من قطاع
اخر من المكان اللي كان فيه وطرحت قبل
ثلاث سنوات لانها لم تنفذ تخيلي اضطروا
الى اغلاق يمكن ثلاثه او اربعه فروع وكاله
ضربه قاسمه لاسمهم لنشاطهم واللي مبيعاتهم
في النهايه راح اطبقوا الاقتراح قبل ثلاث
هذا هو المدير نفسه طالما ما في متابعه
للانتاجات والمخرجات حق الاجتماعات كاننا
لم نشترك
واحنا في الاجتماع يعني يكون عندك
اجتماعات كيف نفرق او ما هي المعايير التي
تحدد الاجتماع المهم المنتج من الاجتماعات
غير المنتجه التي لا تحقق اهدافها
اذا لم يكن من البدايه في عنوان الاجتماع
ومحاور الاجتماع ومخرجات متوقعه ومتحدثين
بوقت فالاجتماع فعلا بلاء بلا فائده هي
هذه النقطه الاساسيه خلينا نرجع نعيدها
مره ثانيه في ملخص مدير الاجتماع
المتحدثين باوقاتهم ضابط الاهم هو الضابط
حق الاجتماعي الشخص اللي هيقول استاذ فلان
باقي لك دقيقتين تاشر له باقي لك دقيقه
انتهى وقته عشان اللي بعده ومتابعه
المخرجات وفي النهايه السماح للحاضرين
بالمشاركه يعني انت جايبني جمهور طب قول
لي انا
ابغى
مجال للاكبر مشكله هي مشكله التواصل تخيل
انه احد الشركات اعطوا للمديره تنفيذي
مشروع تطوير عقاري كبير جدا وقالولي نبغاه
بالشكل الفلاني راح
وسوي تصميم ثلاثه اشهر كوارتر كامل في
الشركه ولما جابوك لمجلس الاداره ولا ما
كنا نبغى بهذه الطريقه اسمح لي اسال يعني
حط لي دبليو لماذا الاجتماع كيف تبغاني
انفذ ايش الاليه اللي تبغاها متى بتوقع
مني النتائج هذي انت معطيني مهام اخرى
فاذا ما سمحت للموظف انه يسال وجايبه مجرد
مشاهده وحاضر
كيف متوقع يكون في نتائج الاجتماع واحنا
كمان لا يمل يطراد ولكن لضروره الهواء
شكرا جزيلا لك من جده مستشار تطويل
الاعمال طرادل